un intérieur entièrement rénové pour le
hall des sports de Rivière Salée mais
voilà ce dernier n'accueillera plus les
clameurs et couleurs rouge et blanche
des supporters de l'équipe féminine de
basketball en effet l'équipe ne jouera
pas cette saison une annonce qui a eu
l'effet d'une véritable bombe dans le
mode sportif et dans la commune
j'étais un peu stupéfait j'imagine qu'il
s'agit de contre agence interne parce
que les filles ont tout ce qu'il faut
alors disposition un palais des sports
que nous venons de rénover je parle du
parquet ils ont des installations alors
peut-être que sans problème de
recrutement
au départ de la saison basket féminine
de Martinique ça m'a fait de la peine
vraiment que une équipe de filles qui a
si bien bouillée et puis que bon faute
de licencié je crois effectivement parmi
les réseaux avancées pour expliquer
cette situation inédite la présidente du
club en préparation avec l'équipe senior
met en avant la difficile question du
recrutement des filles
c'est déjà dès 2017 ont commencé à
mettre le doigt sur cette difficulté de
la du recrutement des jeunes chez les
filles mais aussi de la de la
fidélisation donc par la suite la
question du recrutement chaque fois
qu'on que vous sollicitez des filles et
qu'elle vous répondent que ah non mais
rivières salées il y a des
embouteillages etc donc c'est vrai que
pour toutes ces raisons on en est arrivé
à ce point en sachant aussi que le covid
ne nous a pas épargné particulièrement
chez les filles et forte de tous ces
éléments et conscients aussi de de la
portée de la valeur de cette équipe et
de sa renommée nous avons pris la
difficile décision de faire une pause
pour mieux revenir une décision
difficile à prendre mais nécessaire car
en plus du manque de fille le club
s'exposait à des sanctions financières
vues les incertitudes liées à la
composition de l'équipe reste que la
saison sans l'éclair de Rivière Salée
aura un goût amer des années précédentes
les filles ont remporté très nombreux
types de championne de Martinique de
championne des Antilles Guyane et de
championne des dogs